bienvenue sur les chaînes parlementaires
45 minutes pour résumer toute
l'actualité parlementaire et politique
c'est parlement hebdo avec un des côtés
aude moracchini bonjour au miel et
bonjour à tous et dans l'actualité cette
semaine les ministres réunis en
séminaire préparer le tour de vis fiscal
et budgétaire pas de commentaires à la
sortie les 38 ministres ont reçu ce que
l'on appelle la lettre de cadrage tous
les ministères vont devoir diminuer
leurs effectifs
un nouveau président à l'assemblée
nationale à 60 ans et après plus de
trente ans passés sur les bancs de
l'assemblée
claude bartolone accède au perchoir
largement désigné par ses camarades de
socialistes seule petite ombre au
tableau la bouderie des verts qui ont
voté blanc
fâché de se voir refuser la présidence
de la commission du développement
durable c'est comment ce propos nous
parlerons au football enfin pas du
terrain mais l'attitude de certains
joueurs en équipe de france entre
insultes à l'égard des journalistes
accrochage avec le sélectionneur geste
d'humeur déplacer des anciens ministres
des sports s'accordent pour dire qu'il
faut les sanctionner
et avec nous pour commenter cette
actualité benoist apparu bonjour merci
d'être avec nous député ump de la marne
vous avez été secrétaire d'état au
logement puis ministre du logement dans
les gouvernements fillon
aujourd'hui on peut dire que vous êtes
l'un des deux les rescapés des députés
rescapés de l'ancien gouvernement peut
dire ça comme ça ne sont pas un rescapé
du tout comment avez vous vécu cette
rentrée parlementaire on a vu beaucoup
de nouveaux visages beaucoup de
socialistes évidemment espèces
d'ambiance de rentrée des classes vous
faites partie des anciens vous vous
sentez comme la santé rentrée des
classes est pas anciens j'irai pas
jusque là j'ai fait deux ans de députés
trois ans ensuite comme membre du
gouvernement donc je ne considère pas
entre guillemets comme un député
excessivement expérimenté et très
anciens s'en va dans quelques années
non c'est une fille timide rentrée des
classes ce matin on attend avec
impatience le début du travail un
ministre qui nous ont dit qu'il se
sentait comme un vent de liberté fait
d'être dans l'opposition c'est plus
facile d'être dans l'opposition qu'au
gouvernement
si on est sérieux
on répond non on préfère très largement
dans la majorité dans l'opposition parce
qu'un homme politique il envie d'agir
il n'a pas envie de commenter ce que
font les autres il a envie d'avoir des
manettes d'agir si on est un petit peu
moins c'est vrai que c'est probablement
plus facile d'être dans l'opposition que
dans la majorité
parce qu'effectivement on peut plus
facilement en plus de liberté de parole
c'est plus facile de critiquer que
d'agir mais c'est beaucoup plus
intéressant à lire que de critiquer à
l'assemblée nationale vous pensez siéger
vous avez fait votre choix déjà vous
siégerait dans quelles conditions je
siégerai comme comme il ya cinq ans à la
commission des affaires culturelles
notamment pour m'occuper des sujets
éducatif c'est loin du logement c'est
loin du logement effectivement mais j'ai
pas souhaité reprendre tout de suite sur
le logement j'interviendrai bien
évidemment son logement mais je me vois
pas aujourd'hui dans la peau du
principal opposant sur ce sujet là mais
logements dont on parlera encore notre
émission va d'abord passer au lundi tous
les ministres sont réunis en séminaire
gouvernemental pad annonce après le
séminaire tout juste un communiqué dans
lequel le premier ministre réaffirme sa
volonté de maîtrise des comptes publics
entre 7 et 10 milliards d'euros à
trouver pour boucler le budget 2012
alors comment y arriver quelques
éléments de réponse avec jérôme ramier
pas un seul des 38 ministres et
ministres délégués ne manque à l'appel
de jean marc ayrault objectifs du
séminaire trouver des milliards et vite
car il manque entre 7 et 10 milliards
d'euros pour boucler le budget de cette
année à plus long terme des économies
devront être réalisés dans tous les
ministères
mise à part dans les domaines
prioritaires que sont l'éducation la
police et la justice car c'est une des
promesses de françois hollande qui est
en jeu alors que le déficit fin 2011
atteignait 5,2 pour cent du pib
il doit être ramené à 4 5% à la fin de
l'année puis à 3% en 2013
plusieurs mesures phare de la présidence
sarkozy comme la défiscalisation des
heures supplémentaires devraient être
abrogée de nouveaux impôts notamment sur
les dividendes versés aux actionnaires
ou sur les droits de succession doivent
également contribuer à réduire le
déficit chronique français les élections
à peine terminée l'heure des efforts
annoncés par jean marc ayrault semble
bel et bien
voir sony alors benoist apparu on l'a
entendu les efforts vont commencer et
tous les ministres en tout cas ont reçu
leur lettre de cadrage
hormis l'éducation la justice et
peut-être également ministère de
l'intérieur tout le monde va devoir
diminuer ses effectifs peut-être on
parle même de deux fonctionnaires sur
trois le gouvernement héros plus fort
que le gouvernement fillon
c'est une très belle supercherie
intellectuelle qu'elle sublime pendant
cinq ans on nous a expliqué que ce qu'on
faisait nous au gouvernement était
absolument horrible que ça allait mettre
la france à genoux que la crise était à
cause de nous ensuite on a eu une
deuxième période les cinq semaines
pendant lesquelles françois hollande
était prendre un public n'est pas de
majorité à l'assemblée nationale là
c'était tous les conseils des ministres
échec de la dépense publique et au
lendemain de l'élection pour on serre
les boulons
ça veut dire plusieurs choses un qu'ils
ont raconté n'importe quoi pendant cinq
ans dans leurs critiques sur ce que nous
faisions d'eux qu'ils ont fait des
cadeaux qu'ils aient électoraux non ils
la connaissent et la réalité il qu'ils
ont fait des cadeaux électoraux pendant
les cinq semaines séparant des élections
inutiles et que maintenant ils
redeviennent sérieux tant mieux s'ils
sont sérieux
tant mieux mais ça va je vous préférez
que voir au gouvernement je préférerais
que je fasse des économies plutôt
qu'augmenter la fiscalité ça me
paraîtrait beaucoup plus judicieux et
beaucoup plus efficace
il n'en demeure pas moins que ce que
vient de démontrer cette semaine le
gouvernement sait que les options
économiques et budgétaires qui étaient
les nôtres et qu'ils ont critiqué
pendant cinq ans et elle est bonne ils
font à peu près la même chose maintenant
ils disent qu'ils ont trouvé un déficit
milliards et bien combler vous répondez
quoi je réponds la chaussure
ils ont effectivement trouvé 5 7 à 10
milliards d'euros
deux trous supplémentaires pourquoi en
2002 parce que la croissance est moins
forte que prévu sur l'année 2011 nous
avions la même équation de croissance
entièrement final moins forte que
prévenu prévu pardon qui est est en gros
de l'ordre de 25 milliards on avait
trouvé les 25 milliards et on a fait les
efforts nécessaires
mais de grâce qu'il nous fasse pas le
coup de on découvre une situation
absolument horrible si pendant leur
campagne présidentielle il connaissait
pas la situation économique du pays sur
quoi ils sont basés pour faire leurs
projets et pourtant nous dit il le
connaissait le délai initialement que
j'ai demandé ils l'auront
semaine prochaine donc la semaine
prochaine on va voir la scène du 2 toute
la semaine on va avoir c'est horrible
les caisses sont vides n'étaient pas
financés et cetera grands classiques du
genre ok on connaît par coeur je note
simplement une chose ils ont passé cinq
ans à dire l'exact inverse de ce qui se
font aujourd'hui d'accord maintenant ils
découvrent ils sont aux commandes
ils vont décider aussi peut-être d'un
plan de rigueur c'est ce que vous voulez
dire mais c'est ce qu'ils sont en train
de faire je suis pas plaint de plus je
vais parler prochain plan de rigueur
tout peu importe termes là encore je
suis pas fana d'humour rigueur mais peu
importe le terme
ils font un plan d'économies budgétaires
tant mieux la france ne peut pas se
permettre de continuer à dépenser plus
qu'elle ne gagne simplement fallait pas
nous raconter linverse pendant cinq ans
ça fallait pas basé sa stratégie
électorale sur les critiques par rapport
à la fameuse rgpp ou au non remplacement
d'un fonctionnaire sur deux camps dans
la moitié des mini faire des ministères
ils vont en faire beaucoup plus
alors rigueur mais pas complètement
puisque cette semaine le gouvernement a
annoncé un coup de pouce au smic
il augmentera donc de 2% à partir de
juillet soit 22 euros de plus à la fin
du mois trop disent les patrons pas
assez estiment les syndicats voici ce
que leur répond le ministre du travail
il s'agit de pas prendre de retard donc
il s'agit de faire aujourd'hui ce qui
aurait été éventuellement fait plus tard
mais quelque chose qui intervient
aujourd'hui c'est de l'argent gagné
cancer intervient plus tard c'est de
l'argent perdu
donc le fait d'avancer aujourd'hui est
de tenir compte de l'inflation qui est
intervenue depuis six mois pour
revaloriser le smic c'est un plus pour
l'ensemble des salariés
un plus que l'ensemble des salariés
venant apparu il n'y a eu aucune
augmentation du smic sous le quinquennat
sarkozy même symboliquement ça ne vaut
pas la peine de réhausser le smic ce que
nous dit la ministre des affaires
sociales c'est quoi j'augmente
maintenant mais l'augmentation de
maintenance et celle qui aurait dû
intervenir plus tard
autrement dit plus tard y aura zéro
c'est ce que ça veut dire grosso modo ce
qu'il avance
grosso modo d'un an ou de six mois des
augmentations qu'ils auraient dû faire
quand même
quand vous dites aucune revalorisation
du smic c'est faux sous le quinquennat
précédent
aucun coup de pouce oui c'est pas la
même chose dès qu'on a respecté
l'obligation qui était la nôtre pas
augmenté à hauteur de l'inflation
là c'est un petit coup de pouce bonne
nouvelle mauvaise nouvelle mauvaise
nouvelle pour les entreprises notamment
pour celles qui ont des difficultés mais
mauvaise nouvelle également pour les
salariés que dans le petit reportage que
vous avez passé avant hier un autre truc
qui était très intéressant que vous
indiquiez quelques dents avait supprimé
les heures supplémentaires
9 millions de salariés en bénéficient
sur la fiche de paye 150 euros de plus
la l'augmentation du smic c'est 21 euros
du plus vieux de plus c'est encore une
belle supercherie
à la fin du mois les smicards
malheureusement auront moins d'argent on
leur redonne 21 euros on leur supprime
150 et c'est ça qu'on appelle que
j'imagine le maintien du pouvoir d'achat
l'encore permettez moi de vous le dire
je répète le même mot est une
supercherie
voilà pour le plan économique on va
passer à ce qu'il se passe à l'assemblée
nationale et mardi bien l'élection d'un
nouveau président alors le vote est sans
surprise mais la science historique en
ce mardi les députés élisent claude
bartolone à la présidence de l'assemblée
l'hémicycle est plein pour la seule fois
de la législature les députés siègent
par ordre alphabétique ce qui donne
quelques cohabitation cocasses et c'est
claude buffard qui nous relate cette
séance
cette fois ci c'est la rentrée la vraie
première séance pour les députés à la
tribune le doyen l'ump et françois
scellier 76 ans je sais que ma maman qui
vient d'avoir 100 ans me regardent à la
télévision pour l'assister les six plus
jeunes députés dont marion maréchal-le
pen seulement 22 ans
c'est elle qui surveille le bon
déroulement du vote pour élire le
président de l'assemblée et les députés
sont partagés serré ou non la main de la
petite fille du leader du front national
les groupes parlementaires ne sont pas
officiellement constitué les députés
sont donc assis par ordre alphabétique
jean françois copé se retrouve à côté de
l'avocat du front national gilbert
collard mois qinghai qui ne joue jamais
au loto là j'ai vraiment veut pas gagner
la jour un signe du destin
oui mais il faudra qu'on n'est pas
contagieux comme ça sans surprise claude
bartolone est élu président de
l'assemblée ce claude bartolone 298 voix
face à lui candidat pour la forme le
sortant bernard acoyer soutenu par l'ump
mais pas par les centristes qui ont voté
blanc
pendant son premier discours au perchoir
claude bartolone rappelle ses origines
modestes
je dois tout à la république et je veux
lui rendre aujourd'hui ce qu'elle m'a
donné
vous représentez et la plus grande
fierté de ma vie c'est en même temps
qu'un honneur le règlement d'une dette
envers mon pays
prochain rendez vous mardi pour la
déclaration de politique générale faite
par le premier ministre jean-marc
ayrault
là encore l'hémicycle devrait afficher
complet bon alors apparu on vous demande
même pas si vous y étiez c'est el asri
ans incontournable où il fallait être
je passais à côté d'une députée sylvie
andrieux mise en cause pour détournement
de fonds dans les bouches du rhône une
relation de causalité dans le mentionne
le chocolat c'est leur avis a failli
réduire avec lé fait pas être comme ça
dans son groupe protégé par son groupe
son directeur général sur lesquels dans
une république civilisé donc arrêtons
effectivement ce pas parce qu'on est
assis à un jour à côté de loisirs et des
solistes violent absolue nous sommes des
gens civilisés l échange par définition
non il n'y a pas d'échéance particulier
ce une séance atypique puisqu'il s'agit
l'élection du président de l'assemblée
nationale
nous siégeons effectivement pas voir sa
boutique point alors jodar a noté qu est
ce que vous pensez un petit peu de ce
président claude bartolone un bon
président et il a dit qu'il ne voulait
pas se comporter en chef de clan façon
peut-être de bray philippe séguin et no
papara connais un petit peu l'antithèse
côté je ne sais pas si c'était ou
antithèse en tout état de cause
j'imagine j'espère je souhaite que
claude bartolone soit à un bon président
pour qu'un dossier
oui j'ai aucun doute sur le fait qu'il
sera un bon président mathon jura
effectivement ce au ps mais j'ai pas de
raison de douter de son engagement j'ai
pas du tout dire
en douter sur le fait qu'il soit
impartial c'est le rôle même du
président à 100 dès que la traversée
qu'est-ce que de manger on peut diriger
par rapport à ça qu'est ce que demande
l'opposition en plus de ce cas là où ce
qu'elle peut avoir aujourd'hui notamment
une commission mais on ne nous demande
rien de plus on demande à ce que nos
droits soient respectés
ce qui est normal c'est qui est une
évidence est ce que le barcelone
respectera j'ai aucun sujet parce que
j'ai souci par rapport à ça alors ce
vendredi claude bartolone a rencontré le
président du sénat pour qu'ils décident
ensemble d'une baisse de leurs
indemnités
vous regrettez pas d'avoir ne pas avoir
initié ce genre de choses vous dans la
majorité avant sont des symboles qui
sont quand même fort juste un point
est-ce qu'on a diminué qu'elles avaient
fonctionnaires en france
est ce qu'on à diminuer les pensions de
retraites en france est ce qu'on à
diminuer le salaire du privé le smic en
france n'ont donc ça n'a aucune
je dis simplement la cobac bord d'un
bolide traite on les politiques comme
tout le monde
ni plus ni moins comme on serait
choquant que les hommes politiques entre
guillemets ne participe aux efforts
collectifs et donc on doit participer
aux efforts collectifs mais comme tout
le monde là sincèrement c'est du symbole
à pas cher qui fait trois bouts
d'économie de chambre de chandelles qui
fait sûrement plaisir aux gens c'est
bien mais c'est pas sérieux
traitons les hommes politiques comme
tout le monde n'est plus ni moins soyons
simplement juste peu d'eau apparu on va
parler un petit peu de votre parti l'ump
on ce mardi toujours le secrétaire
général jean françois copé veut
redéfinir le socle des valeurs de l'ump
où il ya exactement ce que ça veut dire
mais cette idée est loin de plaire à
tout le monde certains n'hésitent plus à
parler également de droit d'inventaire
des années sarkozy en somme la parole se
libère peu à peu à l'ump comme nous
l'expliquent mears aussi
tirer les enseignements de la défaite
sans accabler nicolas sarkozy une
mission délicate pour jean françois copé
qui doit remettre les choses à plat tout
en préparant l'opposition mais pas
seulement
il ya d'autre part la réflexion qu'on
doit faire nous de reconstruction voilà
on est au lendemain d'une défaite donc
on doit faire ce travail qui consiste à
réfléchir sur ce qui nous rassemble
voilà et cet exercice donné lieu à un
long débat un débat qui n'a pas lieu
d'être pour certains ouais j'ai pris
position contre cet exercice auquel je
trouve aucun intérêt réaffirmer ses
valeurs roselyne bachelot l'a fait dans
un livre où elle critique le tournant à
droite pris par nicolas sarkozy pendant
sa campagne
cette question du bilan du quinquennat
cristallise les tensions à l'ump
nous n'accepterons pas qu'il y ait
certaines personnes qui remettent en
cause ce qui a été fait parce que ces
personnes là ont été solidaires au
moment de le faire elle était à nos
côtés
c'est d'après tu es contente elle
n'avait qu'à démissionner ne l'ont pas
fait donc aujourd'hui elles n'ont pas
accès exprimé on ne peut pas rester cinq
ans dans un gouvernement et après venir
critiquer ce qui a été fait par ce même
gouvernement
pendant un mois les responsables de
l'ump vont se retrouver chaque semaine
pour redéfinir la ligne idéologique du
parti entre droit d'inventaire et débats
sur les valeurs
jean françois copé va devoir déployer
des trésors de diplomatie pour ménager
toutes les sensibilités
apparu c'est l'heure du grand déballage
ce pas l'heure du grand déballage il est
normal qu'à la sortie d'une double
défaite électorale présidentielle puis
législatives
on s'interroge sur le pourquoi de cette
défaite serait d'ailleurs une erreur de
ne pas le faire est ce que pour autant
il faut évidemment prendre un fouet et
se battre en disant ah on a été nuls
pendant cinq ans voilà on peut être s'y
trouver un sens de la nuance c'est
peut-être pendant cinq ans mais c'est
peut-être au moment de cette campagne on
a beaucoup parlé de droitisation vous
même vous avez d'y connecter un petit
peu loin dans la droitisation au moment
de l'impact puisque la ti vrai c'est
parce que libération l'a dit que c'est
vrai un atelier sur une autre chaîne
celle de formation jugée dit la chose
suivante
et je répète la chose suivante je
considère que pendant cette campagne
électorale
nous sommes partis avec un président de
la république qui en sondages et aide à
45 au second tour à 44 au second tour
effectif il ya 48 5
la campagne a plutôt été bonne me
semble-t-il que mauvaise le vrai sujet
pour moi il est où le vrai sujet c'est
que oui
nous n'avons pas pendant cinq ans
suffisamment vendu notre bilan pas
suffisamment fait de pédagogie ce que
nous sommes les premiers responsables ce
sont les ministres qui n'ont peut-être
pas été suffisamment sur le terrain moi
le premier
pour expliquer leur politique une sorte
de mea culpa des ministres vers une page
générale de tout le monde que nous
devons faire on doit obligatoirement je
me répète au au lendemain d'une défaite
s'interroge sur le pourquoi de cette
défaite il ya eu sur moi des erreurs de
fait sinon on aurait gagné
et puis peut-être pas eu un boulot des
parlementaires des ministres des
responsables politiques du parti
politique sur l'explication de notre
boulot de ce que nous faisions mais je
reste très fier du bilan qui est le
nôtre nous sommes donc plutôt mauvais
boulot des ministres finalement vous
dites par novaes rouge pour finalement
expliqué je pense qu'on a un très bon
bilan mais qu'on l'a mal vendus oui et
donc mais n'y a pas eu de problème de
droitisation dans la campagne
moi je n'ai pas le sentiment qu'on ait
une droitisation excessif avec ans et le
liban sont les valeurs alors parce qu'à
partir du moment où vous avez une
défaite électorale
vous devez interne est nécessairement
vous interroger sur ce que vous êtes
premier point mais hélas l'un vient de
voir on sent bien qu'il arrive je sens
bien qu'il ya des interrogations
actuelles au sein de l'ump on sent bien
qu'il y avait effectivement sont deux
parlementaires qui voudraient plus à
droite d'autres qui voudraient est moins
à droite donc il faut nécessairement que
l'on met tout le monde autour de la
table et que cela colle on s'interroge
sur ce qui nous rassemble sur ce qui
nous unit sur pourquoi on veut continuer
à vivre ensemble et à faire de la
politique ensemble en vue jean françois
copé a été assez clair aussi cette
semaine il a dit bien le ni ni qui a eu
lieu pendant l'élection législative et
bien il n'est pas caduc
est ce que vous étiez d'accord avec
cette position du ni-ni on sent quand
même que au sein même de l'ump tout le
monde n'était pas totalement non il y en
a qui vous d'accord avec cette stratégie
effectivement tout le monde n'est pas
d'accord mais il faut bien un moment
trouver un point d'accord quand vous
avez effectivement des positions
divergentes entre les uns et les autres
vous aussi de re la laisse la solution
qui fait le consensus la solution qu'a
fait le consensus c'est le ni ni
ce n'était pas forcément ma position
originale mais j'ai soutenu et je
soutiendrai cette position parce que
celle que nous avons défini ensemble
alors quand il ya un livre par exemple
de roselyne bachelot ancienne ministre
jean pierre raffarin aussi dit on est
allé trop loin dans la droitisation
commis des erreurs
stratégie d'aller vers le front national
vous leur dites quoi vous leur répondez
c'est pas le moment de parler de ça vous
avez tort non je pense qu'ils ont raison
d'en parler mais là encore on peut
l'être la façon de le faire de façon
mesurée et pas sur la place publique la
lettre
non mais sur la place publique ça me
gêne pas on peut faire de façon mesurée
on n'est pas obligé là encore d'avoir
des propos durs des propos définitifs et
on peut essayer de faire les choses de
façon sereine
dernière question inévitable benoist
apparu plutôt copains plutôt fillon ni
l'un ni l'autre alain juppé ni l'un ni
l'autre travail est troisième après
d'accord pour moi le sujet l'élection
présidentielle interne à l'ump c'est pas
le sujet de l'élection présidentielle de
je pense que nous serons en parle quand
même c'est en novembre
je sais bien aller vers l'élection ne
confondons pas d'ailés que j'ai bien une
préférence ou non mais de ma préférence
matinée maintenant je ne vous donnerai
pas de préférence parce que j'en ai pas
et parce que je considère que
l'affrontement potentiel copé fillon
serait une erreur pour l'appareil et
laurent wauquiez les baleines ou les
partitions nous mais ils font ce qu'ils
veulent c'est leur choix c'est leur
droit permettez moi d'avoir une position
et sciemment ma position c'est de dire
que c'est ma position si vous voulez
juste me laissez vous rêvez ouvrir
beaucoup plus simple pour ma position
est très simple je ne souhaite pas que
l'on confonde l'élection présidentielle
de 2017 et l'élection présidentielle un
terme à notre parti politique
si c'est effectivement un combat fillon
copé ça veut dire que le parti de fait
dès 2012 choisissons chantant pour 2017
et que l'autre qui n'a pas été choisie
rentrer en guérilla est en opposition
pendant cinq ans
je pense que ce serait une erreur et
donc de mon point de vue il nous faudra
évidemment quelqu'un à la tête de l'ump
et je crois que le choix
le bon choix pour la présence de l'ump
serait quelqu'un qui ne serait pas
potentiellement candide en 2010 elle
traduit par qu'à ce moment là je ne
parle pas des questions de personnes
parce qu'à ce moment là ça veut dire que
cette personne prendra la présidence de
l'ump pour l'intérêt général de la
famille politique et non pas pour seul
intérêt de 2017
c'est ce qui ferait toute la différence
alors vous les français aujourd'hui on a
perdu deux élections
peut-être que les français n'attendent
pas de nous qu'on se préoccupe tout de
suite de 2017 qu'on se préoccupe tout de
suite les uns et les autres de notre
intérêt personnel
du poste qu'on vend à voir en 2017 en
2022 ou en 2058 son prix nous n'aurons
aucun nom sur ça vous n'aurez aucun nom
parce que le sujet n'est pas un choix de
personnes mais de définir une ligne
politique pour notre formation politique
est pas de savoir quand sera jeff avec
l'éclair allez on se marre des toujours
la commission des lois du sénat examine
le projet de loi sur le harcèlement
sexuel dont l'examen commencera le 11
juillet prochain les sénateurs ont
entendu les ministres aient présenté
quelques amendements
les explications de marie brémaud ultime
audition pour le groupe de travail sur
le harcèlement sexuel durant presque
trois heures de membres du gouvernement
font face aux sénateurs
nous recevrons pour la première fois
dans cette législature des ministres en
audition au sénat
pour christiane taubira et najat vallaud
belkacem les questions sont nombreuses
afin de clarifier une définition du
harcèlement sexuel juge est imprécise
par le conseil constitutionnel
les sénateurs se réunissent depuis
plusieurs semaines au sein d'un groupe
de travail afin d'élaborer un texte
commun suite aux cette proposition de
loi déposée sur le sujet le gouvernement
de son côté a proposé un texte de loi
venir au sénat quelques jours seulement
d'une examen du texte apparaît pour
certains comme un dénigrement du travail
parlementaire
bah c'est à plus tard le texte est sorti
si vous voulez que je vous montre et de
voilà le texte du gouvernement
voilà le texte du gouvernement le voilà
comment se fait il que ya pas une
conversation avec nous mais les
ministres sont venus aujourd'hui cajoler
rassurer les sénateurs
c'était un moment absolument essentiel
dans l'absolu parce que ce que voilà il
en va du respect que nous avons envers
le parlement
mais sur un texte comme celui là c'était
tout particulièrement important parce
qu'on sait bien que sur le harcèlement
sexuel les sénateurs se sont beaucoup
mobilisées le 11 juillet prochain
le texte sera examiné en séance publique
au sénat
reste à savoir si d'ici là beaucoup
d'amendements seront déposés par les
sénateurs
alors c'est que les sénateurs veulent
tailler dans le sens des associations de
défense de victimes pour une peine
unique pour les deux types de délits las
il faut combler en urgence un vide
juridique
c'est un projet de loi que vous voterez
quand il arrivera à l'assemblée oui je
votre projet de loi parce
qu'effectivement nous avons un vide
juridique il faut le remplir
je voudrais évidemment examiner les
détails mais oui je le voterai donc ils
consensus contient un bon texte de
loiron soit quand tu m'as le contexte de
voir en watts pas à point donc là vous
considérer qu'en l'état il est
dans le détail le texte mais le principe
est la philosophie générale ce texte me
conviennent d'abord quand même
les lois ont été vite écrit mme wittes
ficelé dans l'ancien gouvernement le
conseil constitutionnel avait invalidé
cette loi c'était une erreur là aussi
une sorte de mea culpa à faire on va
trop vite on va tous trop vite pour
faire la loi
parce qu'on répond tout ça des émotions
collectives des cas une émotion
collective
il faut une loi je crains
malheureusement que l'on fasse trop vite
sa loi dans ce pays qu'on fasse trop
doit dans ce pays et il nous faudrait de
ce point de vue la ralentir l'inflation
législative c'est beaucoup ce qu'on a
reproché nicholas à dire sur ce que
désire là c'est par ses prédécesseurs je
crois pas que sa propre à nicolas
sarkozy je pense que ce gouvernement
malheureusement fera un peu la même
chose c'est-à-dire que dès que vous avez
une émotion collective
vous êtes les premiers vous aux
journalistes à nous demander le plus
jamais ça
comment se fait-il que ce soit encore
possible pour répondre à cette équation
là en général on fait une loi dans la
précipitation c'est une erreur et le
conseil constitutionnel invalide donc et
il a assez des arpents clients qui se
mord la queue finalement il ya raison de
ce point de vue là on passe au mercredi
premier couac entre le ps et ses alliés
ça se passe à l'assemblée et pour le
parti socialiste les ennuis commencent
avec les alliés parlementaires ainsi les
écologistes protestent en ce mercredi
ils ont appris qu'ils n'auraient pas la
présidence de la commission du
développement durable comme il le compte
ne le pensait mécontent au point que la
veille ils avaient voté blanc pour
l'élection de claude bartolone
jérémy hartmann il y a encore quelques
jours cela ne faisait aucun doute pour
les écologistes les socialistes leur
laisserait la présidence de la
commission du développement durable à
l'assemblée les députés verts avaient
même désigner leur candidat pour le
poste
l'élu parisien denis baupin est ce que
nous avons compris c'est que nos
partenaires socialistes même s'ils ont
la majorité absolue à eux seuls ont
envie d'un fonctionnement
plus réaliste de la maille de
l'assemblée nationale ce qui est plutôt
sa part tellement plus on est ensemble
dans un même gouvernement et c'est
peut-être un peu trop sûrs d'eux les
écologistes car hier matin mauvaise
surprise il découvre que le groupe
socialiste préfère garder cette
présidence de la commission du
développement durable
ce sera pour un député ps de l'indre
jean paul chanteguet il se trouve que
jean paul chanteguet qui a beaucoup
travaillé assez problématique depuis des
années avec une sensibilité très
particulière au sein du parti socialiste
le parti socialiste a décidé tout seul
au motif qu'il aurait une ou deux voix
de majorité à lui tout seul donc imposer
ses choix qu'il aurait fait tout seul
c'est dommage nous ce n'est pas comme ça
qu'on concevons le fonctionnement d'une
majorité
en échange le ps leur propose une
vice-présidence de l'assemblée ainsi que
la délégation aux affaires européennes
qui ne fait pas partie des huit
commissions permanentes
un troc dont les écologistes ne veulent
pas entendre parler où on n'est pas dans
une logique de marchandage et de l'autre
consolation
donc nous avons refusé toutes les
propositions alternatives qui nous ont
été faites en signe de protestation
les élus écologistes ont glissé hier un
bulletin blanc dans l'urne lors du vote
pour la présidence de l'assemblée
les discussions entre les deux groupes
se poursuivent aujourd'hui pour trouver
un compromis
finalement les écologistes ont accepté
leur lot de consolation la
vice-présidence de l'assemblée pour
denis baupin et la délégation aux
affaires européennes
le groupe gdr non plus n'était pas
content et visiblement tout cela vous
fait un peu sourire ça me fait sourire
le caire le tissu sucre de la vice
présidente pour les écoles existent qui
était longtemps
ceci risque d'avoir quelques problèmes
avec leurs alliés c'est leur problème
c'est pas le mien ouais fallait passer
un accord avec eux ils l'ont fait
maintenant il faut qu'ils l'assument
c'est vrai quand on signe un accord et
que derrière on le respecte pas ça pose
des problèmes
il vaut peut-être encore plus difficile
que ce qui a été le nouveau centre pour
vous ceux là encore je vous répète c'est
leur problème ils géreront leur majorité
comme ils l'entendent
qu'ils assument leurs accords électoraux
avec les communistes avec les verts
c'est leur problème d'un petit bonhomme
jean louis borloo l'a créé aussi un
groupe à l'assemblée nationale il votera
aussi quelques textes une opposition
vérité at il dit qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
écoutez il a réussi je crois un joli
coup
ils essaient de faire émerger sa
sensibilité centriste moi je répète que
je reste convaincu que cette sensibilité
centriste doit se retrouver au sein de
l'ump et que l'ump doit marcher sur deux
piliers un pilier effectivement d'une
droite que je qualifierais de d'ouverte
de moderne de généreuses un pilier avec
une droite plus régaliennes plus fort
plus en plus populaire entre guy et que
vous en mars en les deux piliers
importants il faut ouvrir
je pense qu'il faudrait effectivement
que nous ayons comme c'était l'ambition
originelle de l'ump un parti politique
qui va de la droite au centre droit qui
acceptent les différentes sensibilités
et qui marche sur deux jambes sur
aujourd'hui les deux jambes qui sont
celles de notre formation pré série
mondiale jean louis borloo de réintégrer
lui demande effectivement faux jugements
pas fera ce qu'il veut je souhaite
j'aimerais je pense qu'il serait
judicieux qu'il réintègre ump benoist
apparu nous allons nous arrêter un
instant sur un thème qui vous est cher
le logement vous en avez été bien sûr le
ministre le gouvernement fillon on le
rappelle la loi dalo sur le droit au
logement opposable fête ses cinq ans la
loi permet aux personnes sans domicile
ou en voie d'exclusion sans possibilité
de se reloger de bénéficier d'un
logement
le sénateur socialiste claude dilain
ancien maire de clichy sous bois on a
dressé en commission un bilan pour le
moins contrasté mounir souci
obliger l'état à fournir un logement aux
demandeurs les plus fragiles ce principe
de droit au logement opposable adopté il
ya 5 ans fonctionne assez bien aux
régions mais dans les grandes
agglomérations et surtout en
ile-de-france son application se
révèlent difficiles en région parisienne
plus de 30 mille familles prioritaires
aux yeux de la loi sont toujours en
attente d'un toit pour les associations
l'état n'est pas allé assez loin pour
faire respecter les droits des mal logés
aujourd'hui mettre en oeuvre la loi dalo
ça veut dire prendre des mesures très
vigoureuse un plan d'urgence pour
organiser leur logement tous les
prioritaires dalo de toutes les
personnes qui sont sans logis appliquer
la loi de réquisition donc trois lois
qu'il faut absolument mettre en oeuvre
et puis également mobiliser le parc
locatif privé pour avoir tout de suite
des logements loués vais mettre à
contribution le privé les sénateurs y
pense aussi dans un rapport il propose
aux propriétaires d'appartements vides
de signer des conventions pour les
convertir en habitats sociaux
aujourd'hui rien qu'en ile-de-france 320
mille logements restent inoccupés
comme il ya un syndicat des transports
en ile-de-france où vous voudrez
syndicats ou une organisation une
autorité responsable du logement en ile
de france et donc il va y avoir
nécessité absolue de mettre de la
cohérence de la gouvernance un peu plus
dans l'attribution des logements pour
réduire la pénurie les sénateurs
proposent de concentrer des
constructions de logements vraiment
sociaux dans les zones les plus tendues
mais un chiffre vient contrarier cette
recommandation sur les trois derniers
mois le ministère du logement enregistre
une baisse de 20 % des mises en chantier
comparé à la même période l'an passé
benoist apparu on l'a vu dans ce
reportage claude dilain d'anciens maires
de clichy-sous-bois en bref pour résumer
il dit bien il y avait l'argent mais on
n'a pas fait ce qu'il fallait la 8ième
notamment il prend l'exemple de l'île de
france s'appelle votre bilan qui remis
en cause
il a à son bord sans raison tant qu'on
continuera en france à construire deux
fois plus de logements en auvergne qu'en
ile de france
bon on fera l'exact inverse de ce qu'il
faut faire j'ai souhaité en 2009 je suis
le premier malheureusement en 30 ans à
avoir pointé du doigt ce problème majeur
en france près majeure en france c'est
quoi c'est pas qu'on construit pas assez
de logements on en fait largement ce
qu'il faut en effet pas vraiment droit
j'ai donc réorientée en la matière les
choses quand je suis arrivé 25 % des
logements sociaux étaient faits dans les
zones dites tendues 75% ailleurs
confiant faire le double le tri de
logements sociaux qui ne fait pas où
c'est nécessaire c'est un verre pas
grand chose on est maintenant à 38 %
dans les zones tendues
il faut continuer et il faut que demain
50 60 % des logements sociaux soit fait
là où ces désaccords ne sert à rien on
comprend très bien mais alors pourquoi
est ce que le problème de
l'ile-de-france perdurer ce qu'ils
croyaient après le foncier il raison
très simple pour tous horizons que la
très précis pour un problème très simple
le foncier beaucoup plus cher donc ça
coûte plus cher à construire
premier élément deuxième élément 80 %
des permis de construire sont déposés
dans 20 % des communes
ça veut juste dire que les communes ne
sont pas très désireuses de construire
des logements sociaux ou privés
d'ailleurs tous palaiseau dans les deux
cas pour l'instant non on ne peut pas
les obliger le résultat c'est quoi c'est
que nous devons impérativement faire
appliquer la loi sur le grand paris où
nous avons dit il faut faire
70000 logements en ile de france tous
les ans actuellement on en fait 42000 il
faut quasiment doubler la production
en ile de france tant qu'on ne fera pas
ça les prix continuent à augmenter la
pénurie restera présent et cécile duflot
qui est en charge du grand paris vous
pensez qu'elle va au temps où tout cela
ça vous lui poserez la question elle
j'espère qu'elle entendra parce que là
encore je me répète le seul sujet de la
politique du logement en france c'est
ouais ce qu'on construit le logement
sais pas combien on en fait mais où en
effet c'est au jeudi un petit îlot ump
dans la vague rose de l'assemblée
jeudi 7 enfin l'élection des présidents
de groupe postes très convoités sur les
huit présidents 7 reviennent aux
socialistes la huitième la commission
des finances va comme c'est désormais la
tradition à l'opposition et plus
précisément au député ump gilles carez
le point sur ses présidences avec
mathilde terrier sans surprise il hérite
de la commission des finances
la seule qui reviennent un élu
d'opposition un engagement de nicolas
sarkozy
inscrit depuis dans le règlement de
l'assemblée mon rôle c'est d'abord celui
d'un président qui fait en sorte que la
commission fasse le meilleur travail
possible
et puis bien entendu puisque
j'appartiens à l'opposition j'aurais par
ailleurs un rôle de boone opposants mais
un rôle d'opposant qui sera inscrit dans
un souci d'abord de vérité de pédagogie
parce que nous sommes dans une situation
extraordinairement difficile
sur les huit commissions permanentes 7
reviennent à des socialistes dont trois
seulement à des femmes
malgré l'objectif de parité l'ancienne
candidate au perchoir elisabeth guigou
va aux affaires étrangères patricia adam
elle s'occupe de la défense
enfin catherine lemorton elle dirige les
affaires sociales désormais la
commission des lois voie à sa tête le
quimpérois jean jacques urvoas
françois brottes gérera les affaires
économiques
enfin les luttes paris patrick bloche
très critique sur la loi hadopi
s'occupera des affaires culturelles
seule nomination a provoqué réellement
détention la commission du développement
durable convoité avec insistance par les
écologistes
elle revient finalement au socialiste
jean-paul chanteguet pour moi il n'ya
pas deux il n'y a pas de polémique
j'appartiens depuis déjà un certain
nombre d'années au groupe socialiste je
me bats pour le développement durable la
défense de l'environnement
de l'aménagement du territoire aussi et
c'est vrai que j'ai considéré que je
pouvais donc assumer ses responsabilités
de président désormais constitué
certaines de ces commissions seront
appelés à siéger dès la reprise des
travaux parlementaires
début juillet alors vous l'avez rectifié
benoît paire mais vous avez raison
l'opposition à la tête de la commission
des finances a n'est pas simplement une
tradition orale comme ça c'est inscrit
dans le règlement de l'assemblée donc de
toute façon il n'avait pas le choix
ceci étant dit gilles carez à la tête de
la commission des finances à vous
rassure c'est quelqu'un qui saura faire
entendre sa voix si les dépenses par
exemple lui semble trop importante
c'est pas comme rassure c'est que c'est
bien je trouve que cette tradition que
nous avons inscrite dans le règlement de
l'assemblée nationale
notre ancienne majorité était de dire de
nom le contrôle de la commission des
finances
donc le contrôle des comptes publics à
l'opposition me paraît sain dans une
démocratie apaisée
la meilleure façon de contrôler
l'exécution budgétaire et la préparation
militaire c'est d'avoir un opposant qui
regarde les choses
il se trouve que gilles carez est un
spécialiste des questions là il a
l'énorme avantage d'être reconnu sur
tous les bancs comme quelqu'un de
crédible de sérieux de professionnels et
qu'il présidera cette commission comme
un opposant mais avec suffisamment de
neutralité pour effectivement pas être
là pour critiquer exclusivement par
principe pas de chance comme levier
d'ailleurs didier migaud citant la
chance pour vous à la tête de la
commission des affaires culturelles
c'est un socialiste patrick bloche ou
auchan qu à pas de chance il était très
hostile à la loi hadopi ça promet des
heures un peu chaud on verra bien
effectivement vous savez les socialistes
ont été contre à peu près toutes les
lois que nous avons fait voter pendant
cinq ans
donc vous les acteurs de jeux de rang
bien sûr parce que je pense qu'ils
maintiendront 95% de ces lois là on
verra bien ce qu'ils feront sur hadopi
vous savez l'un des drames de notre pays
c'est que l'opposition par principe et
critique et qu'elle a du mal comme on
doit être constructive au discours avant
le discours on dit tous contrats
constructif dans la vraie vie
par principe on considère que
l'opposition doit dire c'est pas bien et
qu'on est dans un rapport de force qui
est toujours des gentils d'un côté des
manchots
on est manichéen oui non j'aimerais
qu'on fasse évoluer sa banque
effectivement on est une opposition plus
responsable et une majorité plus
responsable vous serez j'espère que
j'arriverai à l'être parce que c'est
jamais facile quand vous êtes dans un
groupe
le groupe prend des positions vous
suivez ses positions assez naturelle
mais j'espère qu'effectivement on sera
plus constructif et qu'on n'acceptera
véritablement de dire que quand c'est
bien mon vote ne doit pas vous allez
être membre de la commission des
affaires culturelles des affaires
culturelles c'est peut-être l'un des
mystères les ministères de la culture
qui sera soumis à la rigueur en tout cas
ça vous inquiète
cette commission s'occuper dassin
culturelles et de l'éducation et de luxe
pour ce qui me concerne je serais plutôt
sur les sujets et du brésil fab a
compris c'est là mais qui ne sera pas
touchée a pris semble-t-il ne sera pas
touchée moi je considère que tous les
ministères de cette couche est donc le
mi5 y compris l'éducation nationale
aujourd'hui le problème d'éducation
nationale c'est par rome de manque de
postes s'apprennent d'organisation sans
n'a strictement rien à voir
nous avons eu cinq cent mille élèves de
moins ces vingt dernières années
cinq cent mille élèves de moins c'est
pas illogique de réduire le nombre de
postes
ça change pas l'encadrement dans les cas
ça changera le nombre d'élèves par
classe puisque vous avez moins élèves
donc acceptons qui est moins de profs
quand ils moins d'élèves s'est résumé le
problème de l'éducation nationale au
nombre de postes c'est se masquer la
réalité des choses s'est passé à côté
des vrais problèmes dans l'opposition
non j'ai défendu la même position j'ai
défendu exactement les mêmes
propositions pendant cinq ans et je
continue à assumer ce qu'a fait luc
chatel est ce qu'on fait est-ce qu'il
avait darcos réduire le nombre de
passages des quatre nationale je dois
par us que vous aimez le football ça
notre sujet oui comme tout le monde le
vrai celui là se dresse à 10,0 dont
celui sur le terrain et peut-être vous
avez regardé les matchs de l'équipe de
france pendant l'euro oui c'est pas
toujours beaucoup plus clair que dans le
mythique on parlait d'enfants gâtés
bonnes mains des enfants mal élevés les
bleus ont aggravé mis à leur mauvaise
réputation à l'issue du quart de finale
certains joueurs comme samir nasri en
premier attirant par leur comportement
les foudres de tous dès lors la question
du versement de leur prime de 140 mille
euros est posée sophie normand il y à la
mauvaise performance sportive des bleus
il ya surtout en dehors du terrain
l'attitude contestable de 90
du insultes à l'égard des journalistes
geste d'humeur déplacer accrochage avec
le sélectionneur
tout le monde s'accorde pour dire qu'il
faut sanctionner vous distinguer
plusieurs chaudes ya eu des insultes de
nasri il ya des sanctions sportives la
fédération a les outils pour le
sanctionner parce que c'est une attitude
qui n'est pas acceptable
il s'agit que la fédération fasse preuve
de fermeté par rapport à de tels
comportements
mais ce qui est plus générale c'est
quelle est la place aujourd'hui de la
sélection dans l'équipe nationale par
rapport à la carrière dans le club
professionnel les bleus se
désintéresserait type de la sélection
nationale
la question fait rire jaune lorsque l'on
sait que leur élimination en quart de
finale de l'euro devrait leur apporter
plus de 100000 euros une prime négociée
avec la fédération française de football
avant le début de la compétition est
aujourd'hui contestée par beaucoup
c'est à la fédération devra avec les
quelques joueurs qui ont dérapé
si effectivement il n'y a pas lieu de
prendre des sanctions d'une part que ses
joueurs en fassent un peu amende
honorable en disant pas cette prime on
va la donner à telle ou telle
association caricative ou même en foot
au foot amateur
je lui dirai d'autant plus que quand on
connaît leur niveau de salaire de base
on peut estimer que cette prime n'est
pas totalement indispensable à l'heure à
leur survie entre guillemets problème de
formation d'éducation d'encadrement
jeune homme pris dans l'engrenage d'un
football business des thèmes sur
lesquels la fff devra aussi se pencher
benoist apparu
claude bartolone le nouveau président de
l'assemblée nationale interrogé sur
cette question des primes à 10 des
joueurs ce sont des machines à jouer à
oka ses déprimes êtes d'accord
je suis prêt si c'est ça distinguons là
encore les choses et si on peut être de
mettre un peu de nuance
si j'ai bien compris il ya quatre
joueurs condé connaît pas tous quatre
sur quoi 29 23 23 pardon 423 pourquoi
vous n'allez sais que vous allez
sanctionné 23 personnes quand on a
quatre qui ont déconné sanctionnons ces
quatre là supprimons la prime pour ces
quatre là pourquoi les autres ce qu'on
fait le boulot cofco mouillé le maillot
comme on dit en termes sportifs qui se
sont défoncés sur le terrain seraient
punis y'a pas de raison
punis sont ceux qui décollent pas les
autres donc on le relève leurs primes
pour ses 80 pas ces quatre là pour ceux
effectivement qui insulte on doit
clairement senti sur le terrain qu'ils
étaient ailleurs
et bien cela il ya aucune raison
et pour ça vous intéresse elle et
l'éducatif à l'éducation il ya un vrai
problème sur les centres de formation
notamment
oui il ya un problème peut-être sur les
centres de formation il ya surtout une
difficulté me semble-t-il c'est quand
vous avez 20 ans 21 ans 22 ans et que
vous touchez ce qu'elle ouvrier gagne
pendant toute sa vie en un mois
forcément ça vous monte à la tête
quant à 21 ou 22 ans vous toucher 200
300 400 mille euros par mois ça vous
monte nécessairement à la tête ce qu'on
appelle le melon
comme on dit et en général quand vous
avez le melon vous avez un très mauvais
comportement ça peut pas s'accompagner
ça sur un plan éducatif comme on faisait
les joueurs du loto là les gagnants du
loto qu'on accompagne dans leur savez
sûrement sa compagne est sûrement je
vois mal comment la loi pour dire
très bien en la matière je sais pas
comment faire spécialiste en la matière
et j'imagine qu'effectivement un acte
éducatif et d'accompagnement
psychologique ou je ne sais quoi serait
utile le problème de fond c'est de
savoir effectivement si quelqu'un à 20
ans de gagner quatre cent mille euros
par mois on va terminer cette émission
avec une image la visite à paris de
l'emblème de l'opposition aux dictatures
aung san suu kyi prix nobel de la paix
fer de lance de l'opposition birmane
elle a été reçu à l'elysée mais aussi
par les présidents de l'assemblée puis
du sénat à paris elle s'est dit prête à
exercer le pouvoir si son parti
l'emportait aux élections élections
législatives prévues en 2015
voilà c'est sur cette image qu'on se
quitte merci benoist apparu d'avoir si
peu parlé et on se retrouve non michael
la semaine prochaine